(audience clapping)
- Oh, my gosh! We kind
of match, all of us.
- Yeah.
- Like we're all kind of
in the same zone.
- Yeah. Complimentary.
- Yeah.
- Very fashion.
- How are you?
- I'm so good.
- Yeah. Have you all met?
- I love coming here.
We met like a while ago.
- Yeah.
- I was on your show.
I'll never forget cause it was the night
of my very first album release.
And it was like the craziest day ever.
I was up to like,
I mean, that was at The Late Show.
- Yes.
- So I was there
at like midnight.
- Yeah.
- I'd been up all day.
And I remember,
I was your like guest bartender.
- Yes.
- And I couldn't drink yet
'cause I was like underage.
- She was so young.
- We served something like
milk and cookies or something.
- Yes, yes.
- I don't know.(indistinct)
- We put you behind
the milk and cookie bar
because she was under age.
- Like juice box bar.
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- It was fun, it was a good time.
- [Kelly Clarkson] It is,
that's the tricky part
about your show my man,
though they usually
have us doing a full day
and then we get there.
And then you serve us alcohol.
And then it's like, this is just a recipe
for honesty that maybe we don't wanna-
- That is the point.
(host and audience laughing)
- Yeah it's like
so late already.
- And 'cause it's so late
and you're like, "Oh
no, where's my filter?"
(host laughing)
- Anyway, that's the
brilliant part of your show.
So your birthday is tomorrow.
- [Kelly Clarkson] That's so exciting.
- Happy birthday.
- Thank you.
- So are you.
- December baby.
- I know. I love that.
So are you looking forward
to like almost being in your 30s?
- Yeah, I'm inching closer. I'll be 29.
- I know.
- So, it's like,
yeah I need all the advice.
- My 30s were cooler than my 20s.
- Really, I hear that a lot.
- Yeah, I'm in my,
very sure my 40s will
be cooler than my 30s
- Yeah, you just getting better.
(laughing)
(audience laughing)
- No, it does keep getting better.
I will tell you.
I feel like,
do you feel like that as
you age, you get like,
I don't know, like wiser or more like.
- I mean that's the goal,
I feel like, right.
- Yeah
- It's like hopefully we get better
as we get older, but yeah.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- But no, I'm excited though.
I think there's something
about like stepping
into my 30s.
It's like, it doesn't feel super scary.
I'm like,
"Okay, I'm kind of becoming more
of like who I am and stop caring
about what people think, I guess.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- Stepping into that.
So, we'll see.
I think music will be more fun
to just like trying new things.
- Oh my gosh! and with your voice,
like you can sing anything so.
- You too.
- Yeah, whatever.
(audience laughing)
You're like a run queen.
I'm like Oh my God.
- I fan girl over you,
every time I'm here.
- Dido.
- Literally I remember us
running into a long time ago.
I was just like, God,
your voice is incredible.
You can literally sing anything.
I got to ask you though.
What's like your favorite decade so far?
- It's always the decade I'm in.
I always think it's the best.
- Oh, I love that.
- Yes.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- It's always the best.
We're also fortunate being here.
- [Kelly Clarkson] I think
you're living the right way.
When you say that.
When you answer it like that.
Yeah.
- Honestly.
- Do you ever run
into those people that are like,
"Oh my God, I miss high school."
And I'm like, what?
- Yeah right.
- Yeah.
- I was like, I could not wait
to get out of high school.
- [Tori Kelly] Yeah.
- I was like, but you go
to these people and they're like,
"Oh, I just loved it."
And I'm like, no.
- No.
- I Loved it.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh my God.
- I did.
It's not that I hated it.
It's just that I wouldn't
be like, let's repeat that.
- Yeah, no. I don't need to go back.
But I loved it.
- [Tori Kelly] Yeah, it's
like, let's leave it there.
- [Andy Cohen] Right.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Way back there.
So your new movie is Sing 2.
- That's a great segue. I love that.
- [Kelly Clarkson] You're welcome.
- [Kelly Clarkson] This is like-
- You're so good at this.
- I'm such a host.
- You are.
- No, but I love Sing.
My family, we love Sing.
So we're so excited about seeing Sing 2.
So like, what's happening in Sing 2.
- So Sing and Sing one,
if you guys saw it.
It's, I play a character named
Nina and she's really shy.
She's this really cute elephant.
And she has terrible stage fright.
So we get to kind of see her, you know,
like overcome that stage fright.
But in the second film,
she is a little more confident on stage
but now she's just as shy
because she's actually falling in love
for the first time,
She has her first crush.
So we get to see her
kind of navigating that.
And, it's really sweet.
Pharrell actually plays the,
like the crush he's amazing.
And the cast is just like so
incredible, like again, so.
- I know it's such an incredible cast
the first time around and I'm still
in awe of don't you worry about a thing.
That last song, if you have not seen,
like that's not an easy song.
People don't want to cover that song.
Like it's a hard song.
- I don't wanna sing it
all the time.
- But how you did it was incredible.
It was just incredible.
It's anyway, are we in for
like some big musicals?
- There's some big, yeah.
There's some more songs, big songs.
- [Kelly Clarkson] I love it.
- They just did a phenomenal job.
I think it's like as good if not better
than the first.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh, that's cool.
- If you love the first one like you have,
you'll absolutely love this.
- Like I loved it.
Like my kids would leave the room
and I'd still be sitting and watching.
It's like, it's definitely
like not just for kids.
- [Kelly Clarkson] It's for like everyone.
Yeah, have you seen Sing the first one?
You got to see it with Benjamin.
- I'm dying to.
- Okay. It's so good.
He's gonna love it.
So wait,
so you have a new kid's book as well,
which I think is awesome.
- [Tori Kelly] Yes.
- So can you tell us about it real quick?
- Yes. It's called the Curly Girl Blues
and, I'm curly girl hair
or curly haired girl. Yeah.
So growing, however you say that,
growing up I had curly hair
and I just, I didn't like it at all.
I hated it.
And so the inspiration for
this book is kind of like
to hopefully inspire other kids,
just embrace what makes them unique
and you know, learn to love yourself
and also celebrate the
differences around us too
like celebrating different
qualities in each other.
And yeah.
- I think it's so funny
how you saw that as like,
oh my God, I'm sitting out in,
my eyes.
Like, that's one of the
things I love about you.
Every time I see your hair
always looks fantastic.
So, it's so funny. Yeah.
- It was a journey,
you know, getting here.
It's like, sometimes like embrace it.
And like,
it's like a thing now
which is so weird now.
But as a kid.
Yeah. I mean, it's it,
I just didn't know what to do
with my hair at all. So yeah.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh, I love it.
I always wanted curly hair
'cause mine was like straight
and boring, but whatever.
Anyway, thank you God.
And thank you for this extra
hair that I've added today.
But I bought it. So it's mine.